how long were you locked up for three
years uh three and a half the last time
right yeah
because you had the YG record it was
u-y-g-i-a-d yeah and then I had just
dropped with Chris Brown right after
that and then you ended up locked up
yeah so it was like a bad it was
terrible because you obviously get close
with Chris Brown from that kidding tour
with fetty WAP right yeah well no I was
cool with Chris
yeah Tiana Taylor I just was talking
about that yeah it was crazy uh
French Montana French was on it yeah
because French was he was coming out
with Chris yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I was actually that tour might have
ended our friendship more than you and
Chris's yeah oh wow
I have no idea that's when he was like
running around with like every blood in
L.A on tour yeah everybody was there
what was that guy's name kid red kid red
yeah yeah so I don't know what the [__]
happened yeah Manish was opening the
tour yeah Compton Menace was the first
guy to open the first year it was the
first dude yeah yeah it went Compton
Tiana and it went the Migos it was a
very random tour and it was a whole lot
of controversy behind that line who was
opening whoa because I remember Kid Ink
went on after the Migos and at that time
I was like I don't know
Omarion went on after Kid Ink and it
didn't make sense no no no did he go on
I think Omarion went on after Kid Ink
there was something involving ink where
it just Omarion with oh no kid ink was
right behind Chris Chris oh so did
Omarion think he should be yeah
he got over that because of the hits or
whatever the case was but Omarion was at
the half I think he wasn't really
tripping tripping like I don't want to
piss nothing that's what it was because
I remember hearing about it all right so
this I went it went uh
I think he had to go before fetty WAP
he had to go before fetty WAP he like
fetty WAP new and I wasn't doing Chris
like this when when they was going on
tour with us yeah I mean did ink go on
after fetty wiper before
he went on after fetty that's who I'm
thinking there's just no way at that
time yeah yeah it was it was a big homie
move you kind of know at that time
Chris Brown still Chris Brown one of the
greatest entertainers we've ever had
lived but I was on the radio side giving
away tickets to that that tour
and listeners were calling in and they
weren't saying I want Chris Brown
tickets they were saying I want fetty
WAP tickets because that was when fetty
WAP was it was a bit and it was fetty
WAP he's so humble he was paying his
respect he didn't even yeah
he just was like like I think people
understand the 2014-15 fetty WAP run he
was crazy that's what I'm like you go
out there and when he goes out there
you're gonna hear everybody yeah baby oh
my God he was doing the Hot 100 Fest on
his days off that's what that's what
type of a tour he run he was having like
you hear what I said he was doing the
Billboard Hot 100 concerts and [__] like
his one arms were crazy so you obviously
you grew up out in here in LA right for
people who but but you you how did you
end up in Atlanta uh College okay so
where'd you go Clark Atlanta okay so we
know where you're from obviously because
you say it all the time oh see except
I'd like to point out too that the first
time that you and it was you [__] Mack
and was it Sharp
yeah when he came on oh my God oh my God
it was classic bro I was just so wildly
entertained by like the on hood on 6-0
and like yo homie gosh Papa's in prison
you guys are just mentioning people's
names and I'm just like this is the most
wild ganged out
but see people don't see that side of me
because I switch it up but like people
that I've been ganging with that's like
our our lingo that's like no I I mean
and that's why it was just and it was so
funny because like you were just here
like like the way like [__] back was
talking about like catching fades in
prison and you're like you know 6-0 he
got hands like I saw him in County right
Jesus Christ yeah we was living cause
like we was in stores like that before
like now we go to jail we would be like
oh they're like stars like the police
know you celebrity so they try to put
you away because you might have an
influence or people might want to get at
you just to show off type [__] whatever
you can't really Escape it I mean I'll
probably sign the waiver they probably
end up snatching me up to take me up
there anyway yeah I'm saying it'll be
too much controversy with me or like
yeah I mean yeah so uh
we was on the main line we really was
thugging like you know what I'm saying
we eating with we fighting we doing
everything together yeah in the county
they always say that county is like the
worst place yes the worst
and so let me get this straight because
you don't go outside every day right you
don't have a regular program the food
and in County isn't the LA politics are
still intact as to where if you go to
prison the politics swish a little yeah
so in County you squabble your enemies
like if you see somebody who's a like an
OP or whatever yeah yeah you guys end up
in prison together y'all might be
together yeah because if you're a [__]
you a [__] of blood you all gonna be
together it ain't just no because it's a
race it's a race thing in prison right
yeah it's really a respect thing like if
somebody disrespects you then you got
all all action at the fade stabbing
whatever but if everybody keep it
respectful is yes everybody's a gang
member I know it's like it's gonna be
people from every Hood so if you're
going to keep tripping on every year
you're gonna die yeah yeah I felt really
bad like when I saw money signs way pass
away man in there I was like [__] like
see I just found out he was a
non-affiliate though that's what I'm
saying like he seemed like he was just a
good kid who just ended up yeah
so what it was when they put that
pressure on him he was standing he was
standing on business and it's like it's
nobody there to back him because he's
not from a gang so they know he got
money and they thinking that he's
showing off just because he's a rapper
they the only thing they have left to do
is to do some [__] like that instead of
embracing me I mean like be happy
because yeah I mean because I'm assuming
he was in general population yeah he was
he was is it because I always say like
dude if I ever God forbid had to go to
like
County Jail I'm figuring out a way to go
to [__] PC I'm like slapping
put me in the hole pause
I don't want to be around nobody yeah
they gonna love you man it's good that
ain't that I went to jail I went to jail
once for one night
and somehow while being there
bro like I'm like in the holding cells
in Arizona
[__] six dudes just throughout the
day just walk by and recognize me and
I'm like
they're like why are you here and I'm
like oh no
I thought you were in a world where
nobody knew kid everybody knows I'm
using my sneaker as a pillow yeah at
your lowest with a little tissue roll on
top of it toilet paper
I didn't eat any of the food hell no I
was like I don't want to take a [__]
you're not you're not doing none of that
for at least three full days especially
your first time like come on man but
yeah with like you're famous though so
you go high power
me high power is like we're suigniting
everybody with that okay that's what
we're talking about trying to go to jail
that's where soldier boy was that you
you you're in like a one-man sale that's
all yeah give me the one man yeah but I
don't want to go yeah nah just point
that out I'm not going I don't believe
that that's what I'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm not going back either that's
out yeah I mean so you were in college
um you while you're in Atlanta you end
up linking with everybody out there is
doing doing you know yeah doing what
they doing shout out to PeeWee who's a
legend yeah man shout out a long way man
one of the most Mister don't speak he
won't talk he don't do interviews or
nothing I mean he did the bad one but it
was a you know yeah he answered
questions the right way and now yeah
yeah yeah now nobody would interview
because I was trying to no not not will
interview but nobody wants like desire
to say because you're not gonna get that
none of them know it let's just talk
about like you know food or something or
yeah food videos yeah